if you could ask any question to Tokyo
what would that be why did you bring
Gandalf back from the dead he should
have stayed dead that was one of the
great moments would I mean people talk
about my characters dying but I remember
when I was you know 12 13 years old and
reading Fellowship of the Ring and
Gandalf goes down into that pit with the
Balrog and you know fly you fools and
God the power of that scene and Gandalf
was dead he was like the daddy he was
the one who knew everything he was the
smart guy now the kids were on their own
and how are they gonna fare everything
was such a tremendous gutsy powerful
thing to do but then they brought him
back okay at a different cloak on white
instead of gray okay but I would have
left them did good I almost wrote
cokehead when I was a kid I really wish
I had because I learned you know many
years later reading biographies of Cokie
and I learned that toukiden responded to
many of the fans who wrote him and if as
a 13 year old kid I had written pokey in
a letter it was probably a pretty good
chance I would have gotten a letter back
and boy that would have been an amazing
thing it doesn't apply to me however so
don't send me letters okay and live
before the internet he didn't get that
many letters I get like hundreds of
emails every day and also he was much
nicer than I was okay this question bus
was sent by Reuben Bobby yeah Curtis and
the question is in such a violent and
devastated world those george RR martin
thank humanity will have a happy ending
well might be happy for some people
fathers it might not be so happy you
know I I don't know if that I as a
writer that I really believe in the the
conventional cliched happy ending where
everything is everything is resolved in
the good guy wins and the bad guy loses
we very seldom see that in real life or
in history and I don't find it as
emotionally satisfying myself as what I
like to call the bittersweet ending I
think token you know I keep coming back
to Tolkien because he was a huge
influence on me if you look at Lord of
the Rings it's ending is at best
bittersweet yes the the One Ring is
destroyed Sauron is cast down and
defeated
Aragorn becomes king but at great cost
at great cost the the Shire is destroyed
and the scouring of the shire Frodo is
never the same his wound that he
received on Weathertop never heals and
he can never really enjoy the the world
that he's won for others to me that that
ending had a great poignant and great
power especially as I got older and I
understood it you know when I was when I
first read those books I was like 13
years old and you know you reach the end
where the ring goes into the fire and
then you say what are all these other
pages that was the end wasn't it that
was there was the end the good guys win
and I didn't quite know what the make of
the scouring of the shire but as I
reread those books as I do every few
years
the brilliance and the necessity of the
scouring of the shire becomes clearer
and clearer to me and it's a it's a
brilliant piece and cocaine of course
was really writing an American
metaphorical sense about England after
World War Two and and some of the things
that were experienced there button
you know that's that's the perfect
ending the way the end of that book was
just right and I'm not going to tell you
how I'm going to end my book but I
suspect the overall flavor is going to
be as much bittersweet as it is happy
okay okay so yeah we have another
question this was sent by Oscar avi
amore Alpina congratulations
so if you had the chance to create a
story situated on another writers
universe which one would that be what
story would you write and what would you
explore in another writers universe yep
you know I don't tend to do that very
often I like to create my own universes
the the one exception I have made for
that was Jack Vance who I mentioned
earlier you know I edited a book a few
years ago called songs of the dying
earth in which myself and 20 other
writers who are all huge fans of Jack
Vance wrote stories set in Jack Vance's
dying earth universe you know Jack was
around and he was writing brilliant
brilliant science fiction and fantasy
from the late 1940s from world war ii up
until his death just a few years ago he
was well into his 90s when he died and
his work was enormous ly influential I
mean if any of you have ever played
Dungeons & Dragons the entire magic
system of Dungeons & Dragons was created
by Jack Vance they just kind of lifted
it from the dying earth books the whole
sequence where you have spells and you
memorize the spells but you can only use
them once and then they're gone
that was Jack Vance and the dying earth
was a wonderful world so I I did write a
story for that book and a number of
other people also contributed stories to
just songs of dying earth and I'm very
proud of that you know it's a tribute
anthology
Jack and he gave us permission to do it
there's a lot of tribute anthologies
that you see up there which are normally
done after the writer dies so the writer
doesn't get to really know that all
these people are paying tribute to him
because he's dead we did this while Jack
was still alive in addition to writing
these stories everybody wrote an
afterword about how they had encountered
the work of Jack Vance and the effect
that it had on them the influence that
had on them and some very very moving
and eloquent essays by by all sorts of
really major major fantasy and science
fiction writers and Jack got to read all
of those while he was still alive I hope
it gave them a certain amount of
satisfaction but I'm very proud of
having edited that book okay thank you